what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are getting into Punisher max
and the defenders comes out this week
and I figure what better time to start
Punisher max then with defenders either
that or just like wait until November
when the Punisher series comes out and
drop it in we're not going to do that
we're going to cover it now now with
regards to the first story arc in the
beginning this is actually a six-issue
story but we're going to cover each one
of the issues individually because what
Punisher max in the beginning basically
sets the stage for how the Punisher is
going to be depicted for how gruesome
Punisher max is going to be what not
really gruesome this really kind of like
hardcore and pretty awesome now here's
the funny thing if I were if I were to
not answer this question I would get it
of litany in the comment section so
we're going to go ahead and dealt with
that one of the biggest questions people
asked when it comes to Punisher max is
is the story in continuity which is to
say it's Punisher max part of the main
Marvel Universe and so in this story
well Punisher was running around killing
people spraying down mob bosses and so
on and so forth is Iron Man operating as
Captain America there so on and so forth
the answer to that question is not
originally Punisher max is most notable
because it's completely absent of all
the other superheroes this entire
Punisher max series you will never see
anybody aside from maybe like Nick Fury
and that's it that's all you're going to
get you're not going to see Iron Man and
not going to see Captain America this
focuses exclusively on Frank Castle but
the way this was originally done it was
designed to be self-contained with
Marvel Comics one of the things that you
guys will notice is that characters
never really age novel uses what's
called a sliding time scale and so what
Marvel will say is okay
mutants first popped up in like 1963
Marvel kept real-time until like 1985
we'll just grab that date as an example
we'll say 1985 Mongols stopped counting
after 1985 and so what they do is they
say it's a 10-year window basically
meaning between 1985 and whatever is
happening right now it's all happened in
the span of 10 years the original civil
war story maximum-security the Infinity
Gauntlet infinity where all these things
all happen in the span of ten years and
in a lot of ways it works because a lot
of these things happen at the same time
for example while Civil War was going on
annihilation was taking place out in
space the events of Infinity Gauntlet we
can largely assume those events happened
over the course of a day so there are a
lot of things that go on in Marvel
Comics that didn't stand
weeks and months or anything like that
they happen in a really short amount of
time different conflicts battles so on
and so forth so with regards to this
whole thing in terms of the Mack series
instead of this sliding time scale where
heroes never age and marble match they
age in real time now the cool thing
about this is that what this tells us is
that the Punishers family basically all
died in 1976 and so what we know is that
at the time that story is being written
which was really around 2004 I think it
was the Punisher has been operating for
around 28 years that's basically the
explanation that's given to us here now
the cool thing about this is that again
the Punishers origin story is largely
Universal it's like Superman Batman
spider-man the whole nine yards the
Punisher was a guy who worked for the
police he was involved in the in the
Vietnam War he eventually formed a
family the problem was that his dad was
killed in a mob shootout the result is
that the Punisher took it upon himself
to basically fix everything and that's
the coolest thing about this the best
aspect of Punisher masks are the
monologues he begins talking about his
family being shot about how he looked at
their bodies different things like that
and realized that the world had
effectively lost its mind but that he as
the sole man has this own individual can
go out and make the world sing and so
what this does is it actually switches
over to a woman by the name of Catherine
O'Brien now captain O'Brien is a
character that we're going to flesh out
as we get further through this story but
she's basically working alongside the
CIA and so what this means is that in
the almost 30 years that the Punisher
has been active he's drawn the attention
of everybody now if this story is to be
believed as taking place in the real
world the Punisher never would have made
it this long it would have just killed
him or would have legitimate firefight
when the cops tried to arrest him or
something along those lines but taking
this for what it is with regards to you
know a little bit of a suspension of
disbelief The Punisher has effectively
drawn the attention of a central
intelligence agency which is basically
say on a black ops unit meaning the
Central Intelligence Agency is operating
inside the United States which they're
not supposed to do and they have their
own blackops team watching Frank Castle
and trying to find a way to bring him
down now the cool thing about this is
that this is just a momentary thing this
is just a quick little thing that's
given to us the greatest moment in this
comic it comes with a guy named Don
Massimo or at least Don máximo say czar
this is basically a mob boss this guy
been running the mob for quite some time
when it comes to drugs when it comes to
trafficking people when it comes to
bribery extortion governmental
corruption you name it
this guy's got his hands in it the funny
thing is that he's just an old guy he's
turned a hundred years old Frank Castle
does not care who he targets there is no
gray area when it comes to Frank Castle
when it comes to the Punisher you're a
good guy or you're a bad guy if you're a
good guy go on doing what you do Ubu
he'll be him if you're a bad guy woe
betide you if Frank Castle comes
knocking on your door because he takes
no prisoners
Frank castle plays any place for keeps
and so what he does is he walks into
this house on the 100-year old birthday
of this Don máximo and shoots him in the
head and that's a coolest thing because
you guys noticed swear words all kinds
of different stuff but the Punisher has
this great monologue where he says it's
a couple of seconds to shock where
people realize that the guy just walked
in and shot this mob boss it's a couple
of seconds for the anger to set in a
little bit longer for everybody to get
out the door with their guns drawn and
once they're outside Frank Castle sprays
them down with an m60 and that's why
this is so cool is because in punisher
max it's this and a little bit worse
it's no punches being pulled it's no
restrictions it's no well here we won't
really show it happening we won't show
The Punisher killing them off panel or
anything like that The Punisher just
sprays them all down no questions asked
no quarter given
none of that stuff they all just die and
it's cool because the Punisher
references his mindset in this moment
and that's what gives us this great
insight into Frank Castle with the world
being as crazy as it is with the world
being full of corruption and evil as he
sees it the moments when he's killing
the bad guys is the only time he feels
sane by all standards of measurement
Frank Castle is a crazy man
Frank Castle is a guy who lost his
family and believed the only logical
conclusion to that or the only logical
response was to kill every criminal
everywhere whenever he sees them no
matter what they're doing no matter
where they are and no matter who they
are now Frank Castle is not a guy who'll
just like run into the capitol building
you know and shoot corrupt politicians
it doesn't work that way for him it's
just a matter of finding this source and
that's the nature of Frank Castle that's
the way he is it's really one of these
instances where he looks around and he
says okay this politicians being paid
this mob boss is involved
but where's the source who's the person
who started all this you know if I kill
this drug dealer another one's going to
take their place if I kill this person
over here another one's going to take
their place I'll get to them I haven't
forgotten about them but with regards to
the bigger picture who's the person
that's starting all this that's always
the way that Frank Castle works the
other half of this is he starts looking
at these different guys and says damn no
idea what they're doing remember Frank
Castle was forced in the fires of war
the guy has fought on the front lines at
a multitude of battles all during the
Vietnam War him just showing up with an
m60 and spraying these guys down that's
not enough because these guys will run
they'll take off they'll find employment
elsewhere they all have to die
and so what Frank Castle did would start
planting all these different claymores
around the place so they would in Burton
Lee in their panic and a Kaos trip these
claymores and blow everybody yeah now
this is the crazy thing to is because
remember with Frank Castle taking no
quarter
he doesn't interrogate people he doesn't
ask questions he figures it out all on
his own as he goes along and so what he
ends up doing here is not only has he
sprayed all these guys down with an m60
he in turn goes through every single
body that he finds if there's a man
breathing that man dies that's how he
operates
that's the brutal efficiency that he
uses so I'm hoping you guys are starting
to pick up why Punisher max is
considered to be such an amazing story
so cool in terms of how it comes
together and in terms of how it
functions now at this point we jump back
to the CIA again and what we do is you
pick up with a guy by the name of Robert
I believe it's Robert Bethel but is
basically the one kind of leading this
operation at the moment but the idea is
that they're watching everything the
Punisher does they're watching this
massacre at this mob bosses house now
they're basically allowing these events
to unfold our basically building a case
but again it really goes in to the
nature of the Punisher because Frank
Castle knows that there are people that
are out there looking for Frank Castle
knows that there are people out there
that are hunting him down but this is
the kind of a cool thing that goes on
with his character free Castle it's like
a more extreme version of Batman Batman
uses fear to inspire those to not commit
crimes he uses fear as a deterrent to
keep people from dealing drugs from
shoplifting from stealing you know
snatching purses different things like
that
Frank Castle is far more extreme
Batman's idea is every
can be you know redeemed more or less
everybody can be fixed Frank Castle
doesn't take that approach people can't
be fixed and it actually makes sense the
great thing about Frank Castle is that
we if we looked at this character let's
take this criminal let's take this mob
boss for example let's say Frank Castle
were to just go in and kill all the
bodyguards and then hand the mob boss
over to the police well as the mob boss
would get a really high-priced lawyer
and the mob boss would go through and
basically be free of his case you know
be free of his charges and then what
would you do go right back to doing what
he was doing before and so the idea is
that if this mob boss is trafficking
people if he's dealing drugs the punish
was going through and eliminating that
source because who of us would be
willing to look at like a 7 year old kid
and say hey look I'm really sorry about
your parents died but this guy deserved
a fair trial which one of us would be
willing to look at a parent and say I'm
sorry that your child died but this guy
deserves a fair trial
none of us because if we were in that
same boat we would do the exact same
thing we do exactly what Frank Castle
did and that's why this story is so cool
is because Frank Castle is any one of us
if we were in that situation if we lost
a child to a mob boss or if we had a mob
boss that was feeding all kinds of drugs
and all sorts of nonsense in the
neighborhoods and different things like
that a guy that's literally just a
generally bad human being that's the
great thing about this people who commit
crimes if they're dead they can't repeat
those crimes because they're dead and so
it's one of these things where the
Punisher is making progress in some
degree if you send these guys over to
the cops two guys are back out on the
street but if he kills them both that's
two less guys on the street now it's two
less criminals that are out there so
again it's extreme it's very
heavy-handed but it doesn't mean that it
doesn't work and so again picking up
with you know the whole idea of these
guys CIA and so on what we end up doing
is basically picking up with a guy named
David Lieberman I believe his name is
but he actually operates under the guise
of microchip and microchip was
effectively the brains behind the
operation of the Punisher for years and
years and years they worked in tandem
microchip gave the Punisher the
information he needed to track down
various criminals and the Punisher would
go out and get them they just kind of
worked in unison the idea here is that
microchip has basically turned coded
he's now turned against his best friend
he's turned against Punisher for the
purpose of working alongside the CIA
with the intention of bringing Punisher
in or else
on the spot and so again this is cool
because it sets the stage for the future
stories that we're going to see how
gruesome how cool everything can be the
no-holds-barred nature of the Punisher
but if you guys enjoyed this vid on to
see more leave a comment down below if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys with the sub button
to become part of the Rob core if you
guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah
punisher max we are underway and i will
catch you all later peace
[Music]